- Heahmund!
In all of this world there
can be no justification
for murdering a servant of God.
I killed Cuthred because
he and the other bishops,
clergy, and several of
your leading aldermen
formed a conspiracy
to overthrow you
and then to assassinate you.
If Cuthred was
once their leader,
who is their leader now?
I don't know.
But I'm almost certain
he intended to replace
Alfred with Aethelred.
But whether Aethelred is part
of the conspiracy or not,
I've yet to discover.
Heahmund shall be punished
for his heinous crime.
That is not your
decision, brother.
Alfred is doing what he
thinks is best for Wessex.
And we must support
him, must we not?
He's my brother.
Of course I support him.
Good.
Ah, Prince Aethelred.
King Harald!
I will think of you in York.
I left some good
men in charge there.
King Harald Finehair.
Welcome to York.
I am Jarl Olavsonn.
I still consider it
part of my new kingdom.
York will only be a
staging post for us.
I'm here to attack Wessex.
After we plunder Wessex,
we'll return to Kattegat.
We overthrow its king.
Bjorn Ironside.
My name is Magnus.
I'm Ragnar's son by
Queen Kwenthrith.
I heard you were here.
My half-brothers,
and I had to see you.
We had heard Ragnar
fathered a son in Wessex.
Alfred's family
threw me to the wolves.
And they say that you're
here to support King Alfred.
But how can you do that?
We are at Alfred's mercy.
He should be at yours.
Alfred is just as guilty as
his father and his grandfather
for the death of our father.
My lords, I've
decided to restore
his grace Bishop Heahmund to
the bishopric of Sherborne.
We cannot and I will not do
without the greatest warrior
for Christ in this kingdom.
[crowd shouting]
I wish also to announce
my marriage to Princess
Elsewith of Northumbria.
You will be queen
to a kingdom at war.
You'll be married to a king who
is in present danger of being
overthrown and assassinated.
If I were your wife,
I would gladly share
your dangers and tribulations.
I shouldn't be here.
God will punish me.
And help you carry
the terrible burden
that fate has placed upon you.
My gods won't punish you.
I had not expected
this conversation
to proceed in this manner.
I would hate you ever
to think me predictable.
I'm a virgin.
I now pronounce
you man and wife.
The king has asked
us to be baptized
in the Christian faith.
That way you will no longer
be supporting and harboring
pagans, but we would
be fellow Christians.
And did you tell him that
there was no way that you
will renounce our gods?
I renounce my belief in
Odin and all other pagan gods.
We have suffered the loss
of two of our children, Bul
and Thorgrim.
So now I beg of you all one last
time to please bury your axes.
Our real hope lies
with the child
that Kjetill's daughter
Thorunn carries in her belly.
Let us drink to the new child.
To the birth of a new child.
ALL: Skol.
She's gone!
What do you mean gone?
Thorunn, she's disappeared!
I don't understand.
She can't have disappeared.
Mother told me she'd gone
to pray at the waterfall.
She felt her time was near.
She wanted to pray to
Freya for a safe delivery.
She wasn't there.
I shouted, I looked for her.
She disappeared.
You and me are
descended from Odin.
The fact is, Hvitserk, I am not
just descended from the gods.
Ivar the Boneless is a god.
You're crazy, Ivar.
I am not crazy.
I am not.
That is your mistake.
I did the impossible.
I am going to be a father.
I am divine.
And to celebrate, we
will make a sacrifice
dedicated to my fellow
gods welcoming me
into the family of the Aesir.
But it must be an
important sacrifice
and must be someone that
the gods will have heard,
of someone that all the
people will have heard of.
Someone-- hmm.
You don't know what
you're saying, brother.
[chuckling]
Bring on the sacrifice!
[crowd cheering]